there always seems to be a little bit of
a narrative of destruction around
decentralized weapons and I really see
it as something quite positive as a
beautiful opportunity for people to feel
empowered
the founder of pro-gun group has been
posting instructions online for using
three the federal government settled the
lawsuit with Wilson's organization
defense distributed more than 2,500
people have downloaded Cody Wilson's
blueprints for 3d printed ar-15 assault
style rifle coming to a school near you
these ghost guns are the new wave of
American gun violence we're here to
expressly outlaw so-called ghost guns
the man at the center of the debate over
3d printed guns has been charged with
sexually assaulting a child defense
distributed the Austin texas-based
company best known for introducing to
the world a 3d printed gun called The
Liberator has had a wild seven months it
reached a settlement in a long-standing
federal lawsuit reposted all of its
downloadable gun files on the internet
was sued by 25 states and then had to
pull all those files back down yet the
most consequential event for the company
was the arrest and indictment of its
founder Cody Wilson on a sex crime
charge stepping up as the new director
was Paloma hahndorf who had almost no
experience on the public stage and
hadn't even fired a gun prior to 2015
how's the past several months as
director been for you so I guess yeah
it's been about four months I guess
it's been cool I mean I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna say it was the best promotion
I ever got but it was I think from a
business standpoint we've done
incredibly well minimal disruption to
daily operations everyone's really
excited about the coming year Hine Dorf
took over in late September 2018 after
Austin police announced a warrant for
the arrest of founder Cody Wilson for
allegedly paying for sex with a 16 year
old female he met through an app called
sugar daddy meet in a state where the
age of consent is 17 police discovered
Wilson was in Taiwan where local
authorities detained him and sent him
back and he's currently out on bail
awaiting trial but
where does that leave defense
distributed a company oriented around
Wilson's brash public persona and vision
of an all-out war between the states and
the individual there's no middle ground
here we're facing an overwhelming tide
of technological super statism
surveillance and control harnessing of
the financial networks the information
flows wake up wake up my god support
public key encryption support Bitcoin do
everything you can to get the hell out
of here and support the balkanization of
this overwhelming power we're very
different I think is been made obvious
the last couple of months Cody is way
more comfortable in front of the camera
than I am I think there'll be a
noticeable difference in the way that
the company is operating for sure how so
less less interviews less interviews and
hopefully I'll get out like more regular
content to keep people informed I think
you know a previous star was more
erratic I'm less likely to do one-on-one
interviews quite as much but I do hope
to push out like blog posts and stuff
like that to be able to keep people
informed so you will see a difference
but I really hope that people either the
name of the company and the goal our
mission is not altered at all that's
exactly the same
Cody was committed to this idea of
crypto anarchy is that something that
motivates you as well this push towards
a increasingly decentralized fractured
system and your technologies enabling
that somehow yeah now whether I like you
know the crypto anarchist label yeah
like whether whether I want to sort of
solidify myself in that camp no because
I'm I'd like to wriggle around but yeah
it's the same motivation it just comes
out differently because I really do see
it as a as a beautiful opportunity for
people to feel empowered and be able to
exercise their own abilities and and
grow as an individual like we're so
honed in with all of our
responsibilities and you know you must
make sure you work for corporations so
you can get good health insurance and
just everywhere we turn we're just
trapped you know so yeah that's that's a
big motivation of - OH - to move towards
a society that looks like that
but one of the only online artifacts
from Hine Dorf spree defense distributed
days is from a live poetry reading in
London from 2013 it's the dream that
tests the perception of reality by
candidly depicting or restricting
atmosphere so with my eyes wide shut
[Music]
everything becomes clear you're British
you worked in New York and you somehow
ended up here so how did that happen you
just went there connect the dots bits
sure okay yeah I grew up in central
London and little alley cat really and
then I moved to New York I guess the
first ten years of my professional life
I ran a lot of events I managed a lot of
bars and then I became an office manager
for a media company I went for a summer
Friday lunch when you get off work early
had a few drinks and got a cab back to
Brooklyn with a friend of mine I was
going off about how irritated I was with
people trying to just increase
legislation and think that that's a way
to protect themselves and in my view
just relinquishing a sense of personal
responsibility diverting blame and I was
ranting about this in the back of a cab
going over the Brooklyn Bridge and my
friend James just said oh hey you should
really check out Cody Wilson in defense
distributed and I did and about three
days later my flatmate told me that I
should probably leave the house because
I just been like in this wormhole of
discovering the work of defense
distributed and I just popped Cody an
email told him I wanted a job and he was
like you should come and check us out
first and I did I met him and then I
just told Cody I was gonna move to
Austin and he was gonna give me a job
and then I showed up and he was a bit
confused for a while and then I made him
quite a lot of money and he was like
okay you can come back it what was it
about the organization and its mission
that grabbed you like that I had a
inherited opinion about guns and gun
control that inherited opinion guns
equal bad I think is the general one
like I've learnt so much in the last few
years it was really funny I actually saw
some people pull out because as he said
there's not a whole heap or about me on
the internet and I think I read one
thing where someone was like she didn't
even shoot a gun until 2050
and they also got upset that I didn't
own a gun and I was like it would have
been incredibly irresponsible of me to
have not shot a gun and bought one like
I do I think that's a very strange thing
to have expected me to have done the
releasing of a 3d printed gun online
like the the code for something like
that it just presents a whole new world
immediately doesn't it it's ok well
technology is going to develop in this
way we have this extraordinary
opportunity to use technology
individually to experiment and grow
there's this narrative that's like
always we have guns that automatically
means violence but the development of
this technology separate to the way that
society is behaving and the relationship
between the two that's the interesting
conversation should government legislate
technology in such a strict way you may
believe that that's right but let's have
a chat about that in my opinion I was
really dangerous track to go down
how is Cody's departure affected the
company I've first of all just you know
just I know that you already know this
to make it clear I won't be making any
comments on Cody's personal situation
you know it certainly wasn't a happy
occasion for anyone but I think Cody's
departure has affected us less than
people might actually think and I would
understand why people would think that
it would be chaos because you know it's
an incredibly powerful figurehead but
there are quite a bit of us working back
there so it's been more of maybe a
personal effect than oh now we can't run
the company the company is doing just
fine
of course at defense distributed
business as usual is anything but just
ask the company's attorney Josh Blackman
a constitutional law associate professor
at the South Texas College of Law whom
Wilson reached out to and hired in 2014
after reading one of Blackmun's articles
on the first and second amendments in
the digital age if the future of defense
distributed business rests on hind ORFs
shoulders the company's legal future
rests largely on Blackmun's we've been
working closely with Paloma she is a
wonderful leader and to be frank our
litigation last get to beat it's more or
less continued as was before black men
in partnership with the Second Amendment
foundation fought the Department of
Justice over the right of Defense
distributed to post downloadable gun
files on the company's digital library
after years of losses in federal courts
and a denial to be heard in the Supreme
Court defense distributed shocked the
world in 2018 by reaching a settlement
with the federal government that allowed
the company to repost the files that
means anyone absolutely anyone with
access to a high-quality 3d printer and
that just means you need the money for
it could potentially create their own
ghost gun why do you think the federal
government settled with you
I want to be careful with why I say hey
why why would you settle with someone
and of course I would think I couldn't
win but that victory was short-lived
more than twenty states are making a
last-ditch effort to stop a man from
posting the blueprints for 3d printed
guns online the barrage of lawsuits from
state attorneys general rained down on
defense distributed mere weeks after
announcing victory Blackmun fended off
attacks as best he could but eventually
had to deliver some bad news to Wilson
and his team tonight a federal judge in
Seattle ordered him to not upload any
more blueprints we lost nice to make the
tough call to Cody and said Cody take it
down
but even that short-lived victory had
been enough for Wilson to take his
opportunity with a bit of misdirection
he had made the downloadable file
library live and freely available five
days before he told the media he was
going to do so they hit 20,000 downloads
in the first 24 hours and the files have
since proliferated on torrent sites
across the internet and Blackmon isn't
giving up the fight to get deaf CAD back
online in early January he appeared in
front of the same federal judge in Texas
who ruled against him in the Department
of Justice case to file a restraining
order against the state of New Jersey
after the governor signed a bill banning
downloadable gun files outlaw so-called
ghost guns here in New Jersey
what Blackman says he hopes the public
understands about his case is that it's
not really about guns but about speed
this statute makes it a crime to
distribute a file on the Internet
defense ribbity does not sell guns
they're handing guns to anyone they're
putting information online where someone
could use to create a gun and that gap
between the information and the actual
gun is enough for constitutional
protection not only does New Jersey's
law prohibit defense distributed from
posting downloadable gun files Blackman
says of the laws ban on advertising
prohibits even talking about the
existence of such files I'm trying to
protect speech and when I talk about
that I can't even talk about those
rights being infringed without that than
being censored and the company isn't
just fighting government's they say
they've been subject to what they call
corporate censorship in the past six
months
yeah we've experienced things that even
we were shocked by Facebook won't allow
anyone to share any links to our
products YouTube if any videos even
referencing deft ID codes they get
removed these corporations are saying
that knowledge of this knowledge is too
dangerous for people to have mm-hmm the
plans for this gun were downloaded like
a million times five years ago but
apparently the knowledge that this even
exists is too dangerous to talk about
that's crazy to me they're talking about
these files they're talking about code
they've completely removing any human
interaction from the acquisition of the
code to the development of the firearm
like it's really the information that
they're trying to stifle otherwise they
would have written a different law how
disrespectful to one's subjects I'll
call them to not trust them with
information to say oh you're not you the
general populace cannot be trusted with
this information but for government
officials like New Jersey's Governor and
Attorney General both of whom declined
our interview requests this case most
certainly is about guns the NRA to the
surprise of absolutely no one has mocked
the effort to outlaw a ghost guns the
NRA has been m.i.a in our case they've
taken the position that they really
either don't care or they don't support
it and all right why you act
and despite the First Amendment
implications of the case major civil
liberties organizations have also
declined to help defense distributed we
have a stayed here that's not the
passive criminal statute it's maybe a
crime to post a file on the internet and
it occasioned no outrage the ACLU said
nothing right civil libertarians said
nothing it took us the gun group right
to bring this lawsuit and we've gotten
zero support in the public people have
such a version two guns they're willing
to sacrifice free speech and against
mistake as for Paloma hahndorf she
remains focused on the company's latest
product launch and the continuation of
Defense distributed its larger mission
post Cody Wilson the future of the legal
battles that you're engaged
do you think you're gonna win legally
what a question I don't I don't think I
can answer that question and do I think
we should win yes do I think we will win
I'm gonna be realistic about that one
the best that we can do is just not give
up
[Music]